Uh, today, uh, last,
last Steven's lecture,
uh, late Steven's Steven's, um,
Steven's after after World War II,
uh,
in the late forties and early
1950s at the end of his life.
That that's my subject really, uh, the,
the latest writing that we
will have, um, chronologically,
historically that we will
have discussed so far. Uh,
one of the general themes
of, of what I had to say, uh,
has been modern poetry's, um, uh,
uh, role in, in a, in
a secularizing culture.
Uh,
how the general decay of
personal religious belief
and practice enters into the
way in which these poets
imagine what poetry is, uh,
what it means for them, uh,
what they can do with it.
Uh, it is a habit with me to be thinking
of some substitute for religion. Uh,
Steven says in a letter,
my trouble and the trouble of a great
many people is the loss of belief in the
sort of God when we were
all brought up to believe.
Stephens, however, uh, responds
to this problem, vigorous like,
uh, he tends to see it as I've
been saying as an opportunity,
power and freedom that were
formally assigned to God
are claimed for man,
uh, for the human, uh,
for the poet in particular.
Uh, but the poet, uh,
viewed in Steven's not as a
kind of exemplary individual,
but as a kind of a model of the human,
uh,
and have, uh, in fact, uh, common, uh,
properties and powers
within us. Uh, in general,
I would say that the poet stands for
the kind of general human capacity to
create the world in the act of seeing,
in describing it
very much as Marie was
arguing, uh, last Wednesday,
uh, Stephens, as I began by saying,
it's very much a poet of this world,
uh,
we are an unhappy people in a happy world.
Uh,
the world however, is, uh, as, uh,
the origins of autumn suggests
without malice towards us.
Uh,
original sin went,
Stevens calls the enigma
of the guilty dream. Uh,
this is a kind of exhausted
fiction that Steven's throws off.
Uh,
he lives in a world that's full of sensual
seasonal pleasures and perceptions,
including the primary pleasure
of perception itself. Uh,
the,
the seasons providing at once a
kind of climate to use his words,
a circumstance, uh, um,
as well as a kind of
symbol for this way of, uh,
being and, uh, knowing,
um, knowing our experience.
Um, the seasons are kind of a answer. Uh,
you could save in Stevens
for traditional myth, uh,
providing a kind of a structure
of, of a recurrence, uh,
and, and recovery. Well,
how does such a poet imagine the end of
life of his life in particular can't a
vision of the world that's so focused
on happiness really include death and
loss. Uh, can it, can it really, uh,
include in its account of
the world that is so right?
Can it really, uh, include grief?
Stephen's wants not an alternative
to religion, but as he says,
a substitute for it and
particular a substitute for
the solutions religion gives
to death.
Poetry is a means of redemption.
Steven said, and that, that
adage, uh, and he meant it,
but what exactly did he mean by it?
We'll look at a number of poems that that
suggest answers beginning with on page
two 60,
a poem called large red man reading,
uh, a, uh,
a palm included in a written after but
include a written after the rowers have
autumn but included in the uh,
volume called the roars of autumn.
There were ghosts that returned to earth
to hear his phrases as he sat there
reading aloud the Great Blue Tab.
You lie,
they were those from the Wilderness
of stars that had expected more.
Those that have come to hear him read.
There were those that returned to
hear him read from the palm of life
of the pans above the stove,
the pots on the table,
the tulips among them and other
sort of domestic still life,
a little like that in
poems of our climate.
They were those that would have
wept to step barefoot into reality.
They would have wept and been happy,
have shivered in the frost and
cried out to feel it again.
Have run fingers over leaves and against
the most coiled thorn have seized on
what was ugly and laughed as he sat
there reading from out of the purple,
Tabula. Now the tab you live have
gotten redder. They were blue.
Now they're purple.
Has he sat there reading from out of the
Purple Tabby lie the outlines of being
and it's expressing the
syllables of its law.
Pollicis pollicis,
the literal characters,
the Vac wines,
which in those ears and in those thin,
there was spended hearts took on color,
took on shape and the size of things as
they are and spoke the feeling for them,
which is what they had lacked.
This is a version of the,
the hero poet in Stevens as
a kind of creative force,
uh, uh, figure that appears in Stevens,
his poems in many guises
as a scholar of one candle,
as the single man, uh, as a rabbi,
as a, uh, as a giant, uh,
in notes towards the supreme fiction.
He's called the McCullough.
In what sense is however
this creative force,
this giant,
this figure of the poet or reader,
what sense does it mean?
Does it make to call the poet a reader
with the poet does here is read the
world writing as a kind of reading for
Stevens. He reads the world
as if it were a poetic text.
His poem is kind of reading.
It's kind of reading, uh,
in the sense of interpretation as,
and in the sense of reading
aloud is I've just been doing,
it's a vocalization of
the outlines of being and it's
expressing to use Stevens, his phrase,
it's a kind of putting into
speech of the world of experience.
The suggestion is that
the poets utterance,
which is something that sounds,
that sounds in the ear,
is it kind of decoding of the
primary text of the world,
suggesting that the world
is a kind of poem, uh,
something that can be and must be read,
uh,
in just the same way that we read
poems on the page. Uh, and in fact, uh,
it's one thing that reading poems on
the page can help us to do for Steve
instead is in a sense,
learn how to read the world.
Let's look this figure a
little more closely. Uh, the,
the Creator Stephen's describes
here as elsewhere is large.
Why? Well, uh, Steven's
himself was, he was a big guy.
Uh, he's, he's, he's a large
too because he's a parent.
He's a grownup.
Uh,
he's a kind of consoling and
comprehensive figure in this poem.
And, and others. He's also large, uh,
because he is an abstraction.
He's in that sense of generalization.
When Steven speaks of the abstract,
uh,
he doesn't mean the substantial or
invisible, but rather the general,
a kind of representative and,
and summative figure
made out of many parts
in this sense.
Uh,
the large red man is large because
he is a kind of abstraction.
He is the sum of many parts.
Uh, he represents, as I say,
a general human capacity.
He's read moreover,
because he's vital,
primitive in the sense of
primary and our aboriginal.
He is a native American,
a native in the sense that he's
a kind of projection of a place,
uh, located in it, rooted
in, uh, uh, the place,
uh, uh, Adam after all,
uh, means red clay,
doesn't it? He's read also, uh,
because he is red blooded.
He's healthy.
Uh, and, and, and, uh, uh, you
know, keep in mind that all these,
these,
these are properties that are sort of
metaphors for figures or figures for human
capacity,
for aspects of voice and if soul.
Uh, and finally he's read because
he's a reader, a Stevens's punning.
Uh,
he's,
he's suggesting that to be a reader to
read is to be able to recognize and speak
the language of the world.
Uh,
and it is in the process
to be reddened, to be, uh,
filled with vitality and
life and native strength, uh,
in blood.
What Steven's calls in this poem feeling,
he spoke the feeling for his auditors,
which is what they had lacked.
Think of those, those auditors,
those ghosts who come to hear the poem,
the poem that he's chanting as,
uh, well as well. There they are.
There are figures of the dead.
You could think of them as a
representing dead parts of ourselves.
Uh,
are ourselves, uh, uh,
living in dead ways.
Uh, you can see them representing
anyone who comes to poetry,
uh, in some, uh, uh, state of,
of death or of deadened feeling,
which is of course the feeling
that, uh, uh, the people
in the wasteland have
a think of them as anyone
who comes to poetry, uh,
seeking to know life and to be creative.
Uh,
renewal regeneration.
This is what the poem gives them.
A, it's what Steven's wants a,
that's Williams.
This theme,
it's Stevens is to pollicis that Greek
word means making a poetry is a means of
redemption because it speaks feeling,
uh,
in feeling in Stevens as a
matter of sense of sentiment.
Some of Stephen's his detractors,
which he has,
it must be admitted a view him as,
as a a, as a kind of sterile, uh,
intellectual list. Uh,
this is not true. Uh,
Steven's is fundamentally a poet
of sentiment and in this way is a,
in quite a conventional ways.
A romantic poet.
He has has many defenses against the,
the obvious danger of,
uh,
of being a poet of sentiment
that is sentimentality.
How does he avoid being sentimental?
Well, there's all that nonsense.
And Steven's, there's
the impersonality. Uh,
there's continually, uh, kind
of acute self consciousness.
There's abstract discourse.
Uh,
Stephens is often called because
of that abstract discourse. Uh,
a philosophical poet, uh,
any is a philosophical poet.
However, uh, we need to understand
what that means. Uh, in Stevens,
his case,
his work raises philosophical problems
and often does so explicitly that is
problems of knowledge, problems of being,
which are problems of epistemology,
problems of ontology,
but it's misleading, uh,
to, um, focus on these
dimensions of his work without a,
also at the same time addressing
the question of sentiment,
uh, again from his Adagio, uh,
Steven says a poem should be
part of one sense of life.
A palm should be part of one
sense of life since in two senses,
sense in the sense of
understanding is always implicated,
uh,
incense as feeling for Stevens,
the, uh, the priority of, of
sound in Stevens, his poetry,
which is the primary sense
in poetry for Steven's, uh,
the priority of sound and Stevens.
This is emblematic of, of this, uh,
of the priority of feeling,
uh, in Steven's, uh,
emblematic of the priority of
aesthetics for Steven's, uh, aesthetics,
the domain of the senses and of feeling,
uh,
the priority of aesthetics over
and against philosophy. Uh,
Stephens is a philosophical poet who
includes philosophy as a kind of partial
knowledge within the larger
total knowledge, uh, that, uh,
is a knowledge of feeling that the
aesthetic that poetry provides an imparts.
Uh, let's look together at, at, uh,
three palms that,
that give her a sense of,
of this total knowledge
that I'm talking about,
a total knowledge representing
a kind of unity of,
of mind and body for Stevens
that incorporate feeling,
uh,
incorporate sense.
For example,
the poem that took the
place of a mountain.
I'm page two 64.
Uh,
Stephen's like, like his great
inheritor, John Ashbury, I think, um,
uh,
rope titles and collected them,
uh, and is the author
of, uh, uh, you know,
not just great pumps with great titles.
And here's one
here and in other late,
uh, Steven's poems,
poems that he wrote specifically
having in mind, uh, uh,
producing or reflecting
on his collected poems.
And incidentally, the, this is a
kind of dream, uh, that Stevens,
his whole career,
uh,
is characterized by that is the sense
of creating a body of work that would be
in some sense total. Uh, his, you know,
his first book is called harmonium
and it's an enormous book,
which he waited a long time to
publish. Uh, and, uh, he, um,
uh,
imagined perhaps producing a book
called the whole of harmonium.
Uh, his, his poem notes
towards a Supreme Fiction, uh,
suggests that ambition to produce again,
a serve supreme fiction to
kind of total, uh, poem, uh,
even as that title also, uh, um,
admits the impossibility of doing so well,
uh, here, uh, late in life, uh, in 1952,
uh, he is, uh,
contemplating his career as a whole
in the body of work he has produced.
Uh, and this is a, uh, a
poem reflecting on that
there it was word for word,
the poem that took the
place of a mountain.
He breathed its oxygen.
Even when the book lay turned
in the dust of this table,
it reminded him how he had needed a
place to go and his own direction when he
began,
how in the process of
creating that body of work,
he had recomposed the pines,
shifted the rocks and
picked his way among clouds
for the outlook.
That would be right
where he would be complete
in an unexplained completion.
The exact rock where his inexact
misses would discover it lasts.
The view toward which they had edged,
where he could lie and gazing down at
the sea recognize is unique in solitary
home here, producing a poem,
producing a body of poetry.
Uh,
living in poetry in the way Stevens
has done is like climbing a mountain or
rather it's like both creating
and climbing the mountain.
Both those things step
by step or word for word.
That's that interesting phrase
that the poem begins with. Uh,
usually we use that phrase to
describe what a kind of transcription,
it was a word for word
transcript, uh, or a translation.
It was a word for word translation.
Uh,
it suggests that the poem that Stevens
is talking about is in some sense a
transcription or
translation word for word,
which suggests in turn that the world
was even before it was put into language
already a kind of language,
a set of words,
a text.
And this developed the idea that
the poet and Stevens is a reader.
Uh, writing here, uh,
is an act of rendering
the words of the world,
making them over into the poet's words,
making them in this process available in,
in through his words,
what is the nature of this
translation or substitution?
The phrase took the place of,
uh,
connotes both displacement
and compensation.
The poem took the place of a mountain.
It displaces it,
it also compensates for the loss of it.
The world is somehow lost,
always inexperience.
But then also found again in writing,
uh,
in the act of creation
that Steven's refers to as
expressing his need of a place
to go in his own direction.
It reminded him how he had needed a place
to go and its own direction that that
could almost be frost. Uh, that's, that's
the kind of phrase for us might've used.
It suggests both a kind
of public ambition,
perhaps a also personal or
private escape, some kind of, uh,
in any case claim for
independence and originality,
eccentricity, even. It says that in, uh,
um,
remaking the world in language in the
act of going in his own direction.
Uh, the power, this created
a certain point of view, a
perspective unexperienced.
It's what Steven's will call
his unique and solitary home.
Uh, the world according to himself, uh,
which is as it must be for all of us.
Steven says he would be complete
in an unexplained completion
completion,
meaning the end of the climb that is
creation must go beyond explanation.
In the same way that poetry,
the aesthetic must pass beyond philosophy.
Okay.
Even says in another poem that poetry
must resist the intelligence almost
successfully. He, he's,
he's interested in it.
Unexplained completion.
He values poetry's in exact nurses.
It's an interesting word.
His inexact Mrs. Carry Him along.
As he climbs edgewise.
He edges with the implication
that I suppose on a mountain top,
which is a precarious place where
the ground is steep and unstable. Uh,
you can only proceed carefully.
Uh,
you can only proceed by edging along.
Poetry's path in Stephens is a bleak,
tell all the truth, but tell
it slant. Emily Dickinson said,
Stephen's is telling,
is oblique slanted.
He moves edge edgewise in his poems.
He goes up the side of his high subjects.
Yet in this way,
he gives a poetry in the end,
a view of the whole, uh, in,
for all of its imaginings and for all of
its celebration of imagining for all of
its celebration of,
of poetry's power to displace the world,
to take the place of the mountain.
The Palm rests on a rock that is real.
Uh,
the rock of the real,
which is a metaphor that recurs over and
over again in Stephen's is late poetry.
You could keep in mind another one of
Steven's is adages and whenever it's late
adage is the real,
he says is only the base,
but it is the base. Uh, this,
this can be a kind of epigraph
for this palm and, and,
and many other Stephen's pumps.
And it's,
it's an important idea
to keep in mind as you,
as you try to think about the relationship
between imagination and reality.
In Steven's,
along with the idea,
in fact that Stevens is a philosophical
poet and a kind of intellectual list.
Uh, there is the idea that he
has an idealist, uh, who, uh,
because he believes in the power of the
mind to bring reality into being denies
the reality of the physical world.
This is another mistake,
uh, as that adage about the real and, and,
and the base suggests Stevens,
his last book of poems is called the rock.
Uh, there are many images of,
of material reality, uh, in, um,
uh, uh, late Stephens and
they're important. Uh,
look at the plain sense
of things on to 66,
another late poem.
Think of how many of these pumps focus
on moments of seasonal transition.
Here's another,
after the leaves have fallen,
we return to a plain sense of things.
And there's that word sense again,
in all of its multiple senses.
It is as if we had come to
an end of the imagination,
inanimate in an inert savoir.
Okay,
any continues yet the absence of the
imagination had itself to be imagined.
The great pond, the plain sense of
it without reflections leaves mud,
water like dirty glass,
expressing silence of a sword,
silence of a rat come out to see the
great pond. And it's waste of the lilies.
All this had to be imagined
as an inevitable knowledge
required as a necessity
requires,
uh,
here Steven's is imagining at the,
at the end of the fall,
uh,
imagining what is beyond imagination,
imagining to where imagination ends,
where it tends it's goal.
Compare this to have a late poem
like a circus animals' desertion in,
in the eights were the poets descends
from the ladders of imagination into the
foul rag and bone shop of the heart.
Stevens is treating this theme himself in,
in somewhat different terms.
You could also compare this poem to
Palmer's bar climate, uh, and the, uh,
uh,
will to come to primary terms,
in that poem or the man and the dump.
Uh,
just as in poems from our climate as
Stephens does arrive at something like
primary terms, what do you call it
here? The plain sense of things,
what might be a limit
or base for imagination,
the real,
his poem moves to recover and
reassert the power of imagination.
Even the end of imagination,
he says,
had to be imagined as an
inevitable knowledge and
inevitable knowledge of phrase
that that equivocates,
uh,
as to whether this knowledge
had to be imagined of necessity,
uh, or whether it's necessity
had itself to be imagined. Uh,
which is an idea that that reasserts the,
the dominance of the mind.
Uh, even in its, in its defeat you
could say. Uh, and in this sense,
uh,
the poem is a small example of that
long tradition of the Conti and sublime
where the mind is somehow, uh, uh,
checked and odd by natural
a force or natural powers,
something greater than
itself. Uh, and then, uh,
recovers its strength as it
recognizes, uh, that, uh,
this defeat is itself a kind of
mental representation or construction
external reality. It's, it's
endurance in its materiality.
A is in fact a kind of
consoling fact for Steven's,
uh, which he a affirms, uh, in
another poem upon, not in your
anthology, but one of my favorites, uh,
placed last in his collected
poems. Uh, and in your Ras packet,
it's called not ideas about the thing,
but the thing itself,
again,
a kind of the title suggests encounter
with reality in its primary forms
placed here, uh, at, uh, at, at the
very end of his collected palms.
It was a, you know, a
kind of, uh, well, um,
last poem though, it was not by any
means. The last poem, he would right
at the earliest ending
of winter and now it's,
it's not the end of fall,
but rather the end of winter that
Stevens is writing about in March,
a scrawny cry
from outside.
And that's a wonderfully
resonant phrase outside the room.
Outside the mind
seemed like a sound
nonetheless in his mind.
He knew that he had,
he knew that he heard it a bird's cry
at daylight or before in the early March
wind, the sun was rising. It's six,
no longer a battered notch above snow.
It would have been outside.
It was not from the vast
ventriloquism of sleeps faded paper.
Mashay wasn't something I dreamed
or made up. It can't have been.
The Sun was coming from
outside that scrawny cry and
he comes back to that word,
that scrawny cry.
It was a chorister who see,
proceeded the choir.
It was part of the colossal son surrounded
by it's coral rings still far away.
It was like a new knowledge of reality.
Yeah.
The poem begins with a kind of
confusion of inner and outer. Uh,
the cry that the poet hears he wants to
say is outside and it's important for
him to say it's outside of y.
If it's not outside
him, then, uh, the, uh,
the sign of life that it gives and the
promise of lives continuance would be his
own projection, uh, and
would be, uh, something, uh,
uh,
liable to die with him.
He wants proof that the
world will go on without him.
That spring will come again.
The cry is a kind of elemental noise.
The noise of the elements themselves,
uh,
the sound of the seasons changing.
It is a complaint,
a lament alarm,
exclamation shout for joy.
Uh,
it's the sound of daytime
returning and with it spring
at the earliest moment,
kind of emergence from winter and death.
Stephens is a poet of change,
but if change within regenerative cycles
of which night and day in the seasons
themselves are our primary
instances and symbols,
uh,
notice also that the world makes
itself known here in and as sound.
It's something, uh, life
is something you hear a,
this also is like frost. The world
is again, a kind of language.
It's speaking to us. Uh, Steven's, uh,
in describing it through metaphors and
similes and finding words for it, uh,
is performing an act of reading again,
of transcription of translation.
Uh,
in particular he is
providing figurative language
for understanding it.
He calls the CRI scrawny. It's
a great word. He uses it twice.
Uh, what kinds of things are scrawny? Uh,
babies are scrawny,
right? Old Manor, scrawny,
uh, both, uh, here. Uh, both ideas are,
are held together at this
moment of seasonal transition
when the year is old and
the year is new. At the same time, uh,
that single bird
that gives that cry,
uh,
is the poet's double kind of Echo.
Uh, maybe each are
echoes of the other. Uh,
the birds suggests an image of how the
poet himself is integrated into the
creative event.
That is the simple ordinary
return of the world with dawn.
The poet like the bird is merely a
chorister of voice among other voices in a
kind of harmonium that is total and whole.
In this case,
his c precedes the choir.
That is all other voices that are going
to follow this first one in the morning
that see tunes them
here.
Alliteration is important.
Uh,
it links the cry and the choir and the
chorus stir in the coral rings and the
colossal son,
the generates all of them
in a series of rings,
coral rings, vocal rings. Uh,
and it's a wonderful image of synesthesia.
This is light coming as sound
and sound as light at once.
A kind of total sensory experience.
A Stevens is imagining morning,
uh,
imagining it as a kind of
synesthetic event. Uh, and as,
uh,
the arrival of a series
of linked creativity's all
derived from the colossal son
of which the poems bold
and somewhat, uh, simple,
uh, playful, almost childlike
alliteration and punning.
Our instances are simply
forms of this choral music,
the poems linguistic play in other words,
uh,
displays the poet's power to link the
things of the world through sound,
to produce connections between
them through words, uh,
and is itself a kind of model and a case
of those coral rings through which the
world is coming into being Stevens poem,
in other words,
is a small version of the
creative event it's describing.
It is like a new knowledge of reality.
He says
new because refreshed,
uh, newly experienced,
newly activated.
It's also a knowledge of reality
existing exactly in its newness.
The real is what is new,
what is emerging,
what is fresh carrying change to us?
Uh, pay attention to, to the sun,
and in all of of Steven's his palms,
but especially in these late poems where,
uh,
the sun is a kind of a mythic presence.
Uh,
the poet waits for the sun,
uh, with the, uh, uh, with,
with the heroin. Penelope, uh,
in the world is meditation.
Uh, Penelope, there's the son's bride, uh,
Ulysses wife, uh, look at
that poem. Is it kind of late,
sublime version of Sunday morning.
Another version of the sun,
uh,
of this heroic creative
figure is the giant in,
uh, the poem called a
primitive, like an orb.
This is a summit longer palm.
And I'd like to look at
some of its parts with you.
Uh, the question in this poem,
which is in your iis packet is
it's really the
same question as is posed by,
uh,
not ideas about the thing.
And that is what is the
relationship between Stevens's
poem and the poems of the
world.
Uh,
what is the link between his creativity
or our creativity in this larger system
of creation that,
uh,
Steven's is poetry evokes or uh,
in the language of this pump?
What is the relationship between Steven's,
his poems and the essential
poem at the center of things?
Let me read the second section first.
The essential palm at the center of
things as the, you know, the first line,
it's kind of the,
the theme that he will now explore
and he says about it,
we do not prove the existence of the poem.
We, we don't, we don't,
we can't prove this kind of bigger thing.
Rather it is something seen and
known and lesser poems in parts.
It is the huge high harmony that sounds
a little in a little suddenly by means
of a separate sense.
It is and it is not.
And therefore is
in the instant of speech, the breadth
of an accelerando moves captives,
the being widens and was there,
you can't grasp it. It passes
that separate sense is the
sense that that Stevens,
his poems want to get at
in their inexact misses.
Sometimes in their nonsense, they're,
they're gesturing towards it.
It's uh, uh, it's uh,
the existence of that separate sense,
which is a sense of the whole,
of a kind of totality,
uh,
is affirmed precisely
through its invisibility.
It's nonexistence.
It is and it is not in therefore is a,
it exists in its, in accessibility, uh,
in the fact that it is always gone.
It was always just there.
We feel it only ever in its parts,
which are snack Dickies linked to the
whole like the scrawny cry and the coral
rings of the colossal son.
They are parts that point to a whole,
uh,
Steven's carries this idea
forward then in a section for
here,
he is a rewriting Theseus lines
from a midsummer night's dream.
Um, the, uh, lunatic, the
lover, um, or excuse me,
the poet, the lunatic and the lover of
imagination all compact. Here he says,
our poem proves another and
the whole while, excuse me,
one poem for the clairvoyant men,
the need no proof.
Who are they? The lover,
the believer and the poet.
The words are chosen out of their desire.
That's important.
And Stevens and remember,
desire is hot in us.
What is desire?
It is the joy of language.
Is it something apart
from us? No, it's in us.
When it is themselves with these,
with these words, the words chosen out
of desire, the lover of the believer,
the poet celebrate the central poem,
the fulfillment of fulfillments
and opulent last terms, largest.
And now he's going to start
to get a little carried away.
Bulging still with more comma,
moving on to the next stanza until they
used to earth and sky and the tree and
cloud, they used to tree and used to
cloud. What was their moment before?
Lose the old uses that
they made of them and they,
these men and earth and sky inform
each other by sharp information,
Sharp, free knowledges,
secretive until then,
breaches of that which held them fast.
It is as if the central
poem became the world
and the world.
The central poem,
each one, the mate of the other.
And you can think about how, uh,
often when fines, uh,
images of wedding, uh,
we're of mating in Steven's,
such as in the world as meditation,
as if summer was a spouse
espoused each morning,
each long afternoon, and the mate
of summer, her mirror and her look,
the essential poem begets the others.
It creates the others.
The light of it is not a
light apart, uphill, rather,
it exists down below in
all of its component parts.
Uh,
let me read now sections
seven and following, uh,
it is one of the great sentences in,
in modern poetry.
Uh, it's a, it's a, well,
the poem begins with a declaration.
The central poem is the poem of the hole.
This might seem to say at all,
but rather this declaration, this,
this principle is a generative one
that will now go on generating a verse,
a much as this principle in,
uh,
the world goes on generating
the world that we experience.
The central poem is the poem of the whole,
the poem of the composition of the whole,
the composition of blue sea and of green,
of blue light and of
green as lesser poems.
And the miraculous multiplex of
lesser poems. And again, by poems,
he means well, he means
individual, uh, poems.
He also means individual perceptions,
individual creative acts. Uh,
all our forms of making in the world
the miraculous multiplex of lesser
poems are brought then not merely into a
hole,
but a poem of the whole,
the essential that is compactive.
It's part the roundness that pulls tight,
the final ring,
and that which in an altitude
would soar of this, uh, power, uh,
principal or it may be the
meditation of a principal or else.
And here's Stephen's is incredible,
uh, a rhetorical and imaginative,
uh,
ability to keep going and say or and go
on imagining things or else and inherent
order active to be itself a nature too.
It's natives,
all beneficence, a repose, utmost repose.
The muscles of a magnet aptly felt.
This is what this total being,
this total poem that he
is imagining is like.
And as he imagines it as a totality,
he starts to imagine it as a person,
a giant on the horizon,
glistening and in bright excellence.
Adorne crested with every prodigal
familiar fire and unfamiliar escapades.
We're oohs and [inaudible] sizzling,
such as children,
like vested in the serious folds of
majesty moving around and behind a
following, a source of
trumpeting Sarah F's in the eye,
a source of pleasant
outbursts on the year. Uh,
it's a wonderful vision. Uh, it
calls to mind the great appearance,
the great spectacle of the
appearance of the world scene here.
Suddenly as a kind of
majestic giant figure, uh,
approaching us, uh, with, um, uh,
the folds of a royal garments.
Uh,
that's what appearance is
like for Stevens. And I think
of, uh, the weather. Uh,
the hills of Connecticut
of sleeping giant, uh,
itself as a Stevens
imagines a, uh, kind of,
uh, uh, experience of the
landscape and of the world, uh,
as humanized, a kind of
humanize totality, uh,
that is this like a I kind of generalized
and abstract image of the human,
uh,
an image of the human that is realized
for Stevens in and through play.
Uh, it's, uh, uh, the, the,
these, these garments. Uh, there,
there, there's something that pleasure
children and that pleasure us as children.
Our pleasure. Uh, the
giant is a kind of, uh,
image of the essential
poem as he calls it. A,
and he will go on to describe it
a little bit, uh, further. Uh,
he now says here,
then in section 11,
is an abstraction when he's talking
about this general poem that it's given
head, uh, in the sense of allowed to,
to go to, uh, uh, to, uh, um,
uh, um, uh, expand and,
and, um, uh, have its way,
but also a anthropomorphized,
uh,
becoming a giant on the
horizon given arms. In fact,
a massive body and long legs stretched
out a definition with an illustration
that is,
the world is at once a definition with
an illustration not to exactly labeled a
large among the smalls of it,
a close parental magnitude
at the center on the horizon,
consent from grave and prodigious person,
patron of origins. Uh, here,
man is not created in God's image,
but rather this image of God in Man's,
uh,
brought into being through play
through all the senses of sense.
Uh, uh, representing a
definition with an illustration,
picture and word. Uh, again,
abstract and concrete.
Uh, anesthetic whole, uh,
that includes, uh, uh,
includes a kind of philosophical
knowledge in it. Uh,
this is what all art for Steven's aims at.
He says simply, that's
it. The lover writes,
the believer, hears the poet mumbles
and the painter sees each one,
his faded eccentricity as a part.
Everything we do is apart
only apart but apart.
But tenacious particle of
the skeleton of the ether,
this big giant thing,
perceptions,
clods of color,
the giant of nothingness.
Each one,
each one of us,
each one thing that we do
and the giant ever changing,
living in change.
That's it.
Meaning that's the end of imagination.
It's the sense of, uh, its ending,
its terminus, it's goal. Uh,
but it turns out to be
not no ending at all,
but rather an experience
of a whole that is ongoing.
There's an experience of
change that includes death,
uh, includes our own deaths,
uh, uh, in a kind of totality, uh, that,
uh, is ever changing and
living precisely in change.
Well, uh, we'll go on
to a very different poet
on Wednesday.
Wh.